there's a new development tonight in the
legal saga of former national security
adviser michael flynn the headline here
it's not over yet correspondent doug
mckelway joins us live with details on
this good evening doug
good evening brett lieutenant general
michael flynn's legal fate remains in
limbo while his legal bills
continue to mount today the d.c circuit
court of appeals announced the full
court will hear the case
of the department of justice's decision
to drop charges against president
trump's former national security adviser
a three-judge panel of the d.c circuit
had earlier upheld the doj's decision to
dismiss flynn's case
the original trial judge emmett sullivan
appeared vehemently opposed to attorney
general barr's decision to drop the
charges
his argument was that in dismissing them
barr interfered in what was the court's
territory
that if flynn didn't like the court's
decision he could simply file an appeal
taking on a polar opposite view attorney
general buyer
believed that judge emmitt sullivan was
intruding into the department of
justice's territory here he is
the argument is that it's always been
understood that decisions whether pursue
an individual through the prosecution
process or holding them criminally
accountable
is that invested in the executive branch
and not the courts and he is essentially
in our view trying to set himself up as
an alternative prosecutor
so now a panel of 10 of the 11 judges
who make up the dc circuit judge
uh circuit court i should say will hear
arguments on august 11th
one of those eleven gregory katzis a
trump appointee has recused himself so
that leaves seven judges
appointed by democratic presidents three
appointed by republicans
to decide flynn's fate and if there were
to be a five to five decision a split
a tie then this order would be remanded
back to the three judge panel that
decided to clear flynn of the charges
again the court
has set up arguments for august 11th at
9 30 a.m
sharp back to you we'll follow it doug
thank you